hello there after four years of playing
fortnite it's safe to say the lore of
the world and the rules of the story are
plentiful so today we're going through
101 things you need to know about the
fortnite narrative let's see how many of
these you knew and with only a matter of
days until the next event it's a good
time to refresh your memories please do
me a favor and throw me a like to feed
my ego and think about joining the 73
people who used code adamara yesterday
fortnite law 101 things you need to know
let's go
the zero point is the center of
existence and the middle of all
realities every other world in existence
can be accessed through that sphere of
energy as the zero point is the original
starting point it is referred to as
reality zero the zero point was found in
chapter one hidden under loot lake in a
45 vault the original vault was overseen
by singularity a character with an
unknown past and was never seen again
after the zero point became unstable
according to the father of fortnite
stories donald mustard the singularity
is pivotal to the story and a super
super important character to the future
of the storyline so keep an eye out for
her the fortnite island is in a
continuous cycle every 22 minutes a
storm closes around the inhabitants and
resets the entire island all builds all
destruction is undone the inhabitants
are unaware of the loop as they too are
reset after each game is concluded this
is due to the effect of the zero point
which causes memories to be erased and
voices to become muted these combatants
are taken from all other worlds outside
of reality zero via the zero point they
forget their homeworld within 22 minutes
although there are examples of some
super powered individuals who can hold
onto their sanity for a little bit
longer drift is a character from our
very own world taken from the
californian desert in a freak rift
accident the zero point itself is
controlled by an organization known as
io the imagined order a mysterious group
who watched the island from outside the
loop the imagined order oversee all
aspects of each game we play from supply
drops to the content of each and every
chest even to the direction of the storm
i all have facilities around the island
some in plain sight and others hidden
away including underneath the island we
stand upon to visit the island or any
other reality the io use a bridge
between worlds known as a pure portal
the pure portal can isolate the
vibrations of any world reality or
dimension in existence and create a
doorway between the two there is a
second way to do this using sideways
tears which connects two realities
directly but these are considered less
reliable and dangerous to be left open
as we know everyone who enters the loop
will lose their memories but in fact
there are two ways to prevent this the
first is to bring a portal device
effectively a shard of the zero point
contained in a carriable sphere there is
also a pocket-sized version of this
which was found in the batman series it
was a bit broken though so we don't know
what it really looks like the second way
is to wear a self-contained suit an
airtight vessel which prevents the
effects of the island from interfering
with the user in theory both these
options let the individual speak and
retain memories in between loops
although memories become distant and
more detached after a single loop on the
island it is confirmed that emotions
remain intact feelings and natural
senses stay in place to allow some
combatants to trust one another and form
unspoken bonds there is actually a way
to leave the loop discovered by batman
himself he taught us that being the sole
survivor in the final storm circle of a
match would allow the winner to escape
once out of the loop the character is
free to live on the island without the
effects of memory loss or storm circles
affecting them unfortunately those
outside the loop remain trapped on the
island with multiple death barriers in
place to halt any exodus at least 11
people have been recorded escaping the
loop this includes the first ever
renegade raider also fish sticks
catwoman and the last one at the time of
writing this the foundation the loopers
who escaped found a way into the i o
facility underground using a vibration
frequency to unlock one of the island
bunkers the il facility is protected by
rock-like creatures who can only be
bested by destroying a glowing rune on
their heads inside the i o bunker is the
bridge which contains the pure portal
batman informs us that each reality has
a different vibration each is completely
unique and by successfully isolating the
movement each of the escapees can return
home unfortunately if you die outside
the loop you die permanently and some
characters have done that indeed
aeronaut passed away testing the death
barriers on the island and the eternal
voyager jumped into an uncalibrated pure
portal and was ripped to shreds and fish
dicks was murdered by deathstroke once a
person jumps back through the portal
into their own reality all their
memories from their entire life return
although it does take a minute or two
they also remember their time inside the
loop it should be noted that batman
attempted to free harley quinn from the
loop yet she escaped and currently her
whereabouts is unknown but she's outside
the loop
we need a break for a second here's
brutus okay break over back to work as
we've said before the imagined order can
visit the island via the pure portal but
upon returning a snapshot is left behind
a perfect clone of the person who
escaped exactly the same in every single
way but without the pure portal device
they become one of the loopers their
memories in tatters destined to replay
the same 22 minutes over and over again
many of the snapshots are taken from an
io agent named jones he is regularly
sent onto the island to research the
loop in the name of science he was the
first to ever leap into the zero point
and thus has more snapshots than any
other character bunker johnsy is one of
those snapshots and although the
majority of his thoughts are gone he's
still able to remember small facts and
ideas he told us about snapshots
existing and how the loop affects us all
bunker jonesy was revealed to have
foresight predicting a fight between a
devourer and a mech he remains unknown
as to how he knew this but he was
certainly right and that live event was
insanely good another quick note
following that fight the mech flew into
space it's uncertain where they went to
and it feels like the time my dad went
to get milk
six years ago at least one of the io
guards was revealed to be a snapshot of
agent jones during the batman zero point
comic book series this heavily implies
io creates snapshots to be recruited
into their army of soldiers
strengthening their ranks constantly
there is a second mysterious
organization we should know about who
are vehemently against io these are the
seven the seven we believe are named
after the founding seven members of the
team with the core mission of breaking
the loop and liberating the zero point
they want to free the great orb of
energy from the clutches of the imagined
order the first member of the seven is
the visitor who arrived in chapter one
season four inside a black meteor he
attempted to locate the zero point using
a rocket before causing a crack in
reality above us the second member of
the seven is the scientist who arrived
in chapter one season x
this season included time anomalies
which saw the season 4 meteor hovering
above the ground the scientists then
created a second rocket to complete the
seventh plan
during his time here the scientist also
built rift beacons another way to open
sideways rifts or gateways to other
worlds this allowed the rocket to be
constructed using parts from other
realities the third member of the seven
is the paradigm whose impact on the
story is unclear it's likely she works
with the scientist and the visitor to
successfully crash the meteor into the
zero point but this period of time is
heavily shrouded in mystery and could be
rewritten at any moment although this
looks like an attempt to destroy the
zero point it was actually a perfectly
timed attack to change the loop and
affect the bridge and the pure portal
there primitive voice recordings were
discovered in season x left by the seven
giving us step by step instructions on
what to do with that rocket following
the black hole the zero point reemerged
and the cycle began again on a brand new
island the fourth member of the seven is
the foundation the leader of the group
he is currently on the island outside of
the loop in the final days of chapter
two we'll get back to him very soon the
zero point energy is so strong that it
once attracted galactus the devourer of
worlds he flew across multiple universes
to the island in an attempt to consume
the zero point
his herald at the time thor was able to
prevent this by using another gateway
between worlds to bring the avengers
here he used the bifrost asgardian
technology many of the avengers
succumbed to the island's effects yet
tony stark was able to work throughout
the season to create his own rift
beacons to transport his lab from new
york over to the island
stark used gamma cells to defeat
galactus as he cloned the battle bus a
few billion times this caused a rift to
be created which took galactus and all
of the avengers back to their own world
leaving behind snapshots in their place
before leaving galactus rips the zero
point out of the ground which caused the
chain reaction as the orb destabilized
by the way we know of many states the
zero point can be in fully stable and
vaulted away unstable there's many many
versions of an unstable zero point we've
seen the zero point in bloom we've seen
the zero point enclosed and we've seen
the zero point collapse aka cataclysm
which created the black hole we've also
seen a projected zero point state in the
live event of season two chapter two
which leads me to midas just like the
myth of king midas this guy has the
ability to touch things and turn them
into gold unlike the myth of king midas
our midas does this through choice
touching them alone doesn't change them
into gold it's optional midas was
revealed to be working on a zero point
device under the agency at the center of
the island here we saw an image of his
daughter who is also a character in the
game jules the engineer midas device was
seen forcing back the storm in an epic
battle for power but by the end the
storm won out and the cycle continued
again during this 10 minutes we were
able to escape the loop a few times for
a few moments we found ourselves in the
i o facility and the office of agent
jones he spoke to us very briefly mere
days before this event began the cyclo
uniform was discovered in midas room a
self-contained suit that suit and midas
history remains shrouded in mystery just
like his secret first shadow unit
including chaos agent who has the power
to create slurp beings from loopers the
aftermath of this escape attempt caused
a tsunami to engulf the island and your
mum's favorite superhero arrived now
okay let's take another break this time
it's chun-li
feeling refreshed yet everyone loves
groot dancing let's get back to this
during season five of chapter two the
zero point faced imminent collapse so
much so that the majority of io
abandoned the island during this period
one of the most loyal i o agents jon
jones refused to evacuate and instead
used a pure portal device in a last-gasp
attempt to save reality io most
definitely saw this as betrayal and that
jones has defected to the opposition
jones's actions brought the foundation
to the island and once again a member of
the seven arrived in a meteor
immediately the foundation attacked
jones heavily implying the two know each
other and were enemies from the seven
and i o jones was able to stop this
onslaught by shouting geno
at present we still don't know who or
what that is and we also don't know who
the sisters are either and the sisters
but answers are coming the promise to
deliver the sisters and geno is enough
for the foundation who agrees to work
with the former io agent the two prevent
the second collapse of the zero point
jones with our help closes the sideways
rifts that popped up around the island
while the foundation held together
reality itself ultimately this attempt
was going to fail so a new plan was
hatched the foundation locked himself
inside the zero point to give it time to
heal sacrificing himself to protect the
orb jon jones also made a telling
sacrifice handing over the portal device
knowing that in 22 minutes he'd become
yet another mindless looper stuck on the
island this plan was successful aspire
grew around the foundation and the zero
point protecting reality eventually an
alien race arrived on the island and
blew that spire up this caused the
foundation to fall into reality
nf1935 the dc universe and gotham city
as that was the last frequency used by
the pure portal below the foundation
teamed up with the justice league to
prevent dc villains from coming to the
island through a sideways rift which had
opened in metropolis it turns out that
io is in cahoot with the batman who
laughs and lex luthor and now has the
technology in place to make those rifts
to other worlds without a pure portal
only one dc super villain makes it into
the rift the batman who laughs who is
quickly pursued by the foundation
foundation is victorious and wins the
match and leaves the loop immediately so
the foundation is currently on the
island outside the loop the batman who
laughs on the other hand is now locked
in a loop destined to repeat the same 22
minutes over and over again but plot
twist he's actually not affected by the
island's force thanks to his visor which
was created in the dark forge he is
immune to memory failure and speech loss
at this point we don't know if this is
plot armor or if dark matter is the way
to overpower the island's forces back to
the alien invasion to counter this new
threat io sent another operative onto
the island dr sloan who up to this point
was agent jones's commanding officer
sloan is depicted in images as a child
genius and a long-time servant of the
imagined order using her high intellect
and emotional manipulation sloan had us
deliver bombs onto the alien mothership
which she explodes whilst we're still on
it don't worry we survived this ship
contained cubes hundreds of cubes which
crashed down on the island below back in
2018 we actually saw one of these cubes
before a beam of energy hit the desert
biome and created a cube of dark matter
known as kevin the cube the cube led us
to loot lake and revealed a fiend world
to us filled with grotesque creatures
the mysterious power of the cube took us
into a place between worlds in which we
first encountered a rift butterfly our
first indication that we're living in a
multiverse kevin the cube was then made
into a power source for the inhabitants
who made a nuclear power plant from the
cube remains back in 2021 now and all
those events were confirmed to be acts
of a faction known as the last reality a
mixture of chimera aliens and cube
fanatics the leader of the last reality
is the cube queen who remained hidden
for the majority of their invasion
attempt the cube queen is more than a
military leader she's responsible for
the rift tour a seemingly harmless music
event which was in fact a ruse to scan
the brains of loopers while they
listened to mediocre pop music the last
reality mobilized the cubes on the
island they rolled around like crazy
this included the resurrection of kevin
the cube from 2018 who broke out of the
nuclear power plant and along with all
the other blocks created a cube town
above the zero point's last known
location as i'm saying this the cube
queen sits above the cubes creating a
pyramid meanwhile dr sloane and io are
frantically creating a counter-attack
offensive which includes opening the
redacted bunker we've been waiting for
for years there is one other thing you
should know about a blue cube during the
skyfire event we were able to reboot one
of the cubes which became blue
it has since sat on the map doing
absolutely nothing at some point this
thing will come to life so let's watch
it there's only a few more days until
the end of the season and the event
which will end this chapter we did it
101 pieces of fortnite law the basics
are in place and hopefully this was
useful thank you very much for watching
it's hugely appreciated i'm adam you're
awesome i'll see you next time